and then for the press preview a first
look at tomorrow's front pages and
tonight we'll see
what's making the headlines with the
editor of nottinghamshire live natalie
faye and also the editor of politico
london playbook
alex wickham good to see you both this
bank holiday speak to you in a moment
first of all let's check out some of
those
front pages then the potential for
summer holidays makes a lot of the front
pages including the metro
wish you'd come here the headline
onto the mirror it's gone for a very
similar headline as you can see the
telegraph
says spain greece and france are among
the countries that will be the
government's
green list meaning uk tourists can visit
without having to quarantine on their
return
and the ft reports that germany is set
to allow those vaccinated against kovid
19
into the country similar stories you can
see on the guardians front page adding
that the uk is urging caution against
international travel the eye splashes on
the unlocking of lockdown on uk
shores it says the next stage of easing
restrictions has got the green light
but the male asks why kovid restrictions
are set to last for
another seven weeks and i'm joined
tonight by natalie fay
and alex wickham good to see you both
let's start with the front of the daily
telegraph
natalie it's a similar story as we've
just seen on most of the front pages
talking about
holidays and i guess after a rather wet
and windy and miserable pankol at a
weekend all our thoughts
are heading towards the summer and it
seems doesn't it natalie that
europe is more than ready to welcome us
but our prime minister for now being
pretty cautious
yeah well that's exactly right and i
mean um you know this week
we're expecting the much anticipated
travel review and it's quite rightly
making all the front pages tomorrow
dominating the front pages
i think the telegraph probably explains
it best saying that
if you're fully vaccinated and you if
you've had both doses you could be able
to go to europe next month
which is obviously what we're all
waiting for you know um
there's talk of a traffic light system
and apparently only a small handful of
countries are going to be on that
so may the 17th is the date we're
expecting to hear this
but with a small handful of countries
that are going to be on the green list
it doesn't say much for family holidays
or what we'll be able to do
from july august onwards um but
the telegraph seems to be suggesting
that from june spain
greece and france will be on that list
you can go there if you've been
vaccinated
and obviously that's brilliant news but
it does all feel a bit last minute
quite chaotic disorganized and if you're
a family trying to sort out holiday
would you really take the risk and book
a holiday in spain at the moment i'm not
really sure you would
yeah natalie it's not only families who
are trying to make you know make sense
of it all but you know the thousands of
people who work in the in the tourism
industry
airlines they're all desperate aren't
they for a clear route out of this
yeah that's exactly right and i mean um
i obviously work in nottinghamshire east
midlands airport is on my patch
thousands of jobs people who work there
they can't go to work they've got no
certainty they don't know what's going
on
and that is the sort of airport that
relies on people going on their short
haul holidays
to europe and people in the region their
jobs rely on this kind of news
and the travel industry has actually
said you know to boris johnson
you're being too cautious we need more
certainty we need to know what's going
on it's just not good enough and
obviously that's not the only kind of
quarter that boris is being criticized
from because the pub industry has always
been
also been laying into him for that kind
of uncertainty as well
although they have got a bit more
certainty now but the travel industry
really has been hit hard um we've not
been able to go anywhere for a long long
time now
and people's livelihoods depend on this
so
i think we need things to be a bit
clearer the traffic light system to me
doesn't seem to be um you know the best
kind of system because it can change
all the time and you know it doesn't
feel like
this is the kind of answer that people
want for going on holidays yeah the
government is saying yeah they're going
to try and give a couple of weeks aren't
they between
the colors changing so people can at
least sort of sort themselves out but
it's
it's not straightforward front page of
the guardian eu to open up
to vaccinated britons as uk urges
caution that similar story
alex and of course there has been a a a
a bit of um
controversy within the cabinet hasn't
there and also back benches i mean
the pm is under quite a lot of pressure
from all sides over this
absolutely and we see on the guardian
front page and on that daily mail front
page that we just saw a minute ago
the real pressure on the prime minister
to just get this going a little bit
quicker
you know there's only one govid death um
today
in england which is you know all in all
pretty good news compared to you know
how things have been going over the last
few months
and then in the cabinet we've got a real
that classic
hawks versus dove split that we've heard
about all the way through this uh
pandemic of
on the one hand you've got the the likes
of the health secretary matt hancock
the chief medical officer chris whittie
as well who are saying hang on a minute
let's just take this slowly we don't
want to have a
you know an influx of people coming into
this country
um from from abroad returning from
holidays bringing in perhaps new
variants things that are not in under
our control
everything's going well at the moment
let's just wait a few more weeks a few
more months even perhaps some some of
them are arguing
and on the other hand on the other side
of the cabinet you've got people like
the chancellor ishizunak and the
business secretary quasi quatern
who are saying you know come on why
don't we just uh think about the tourism
industry here why don't we think about
the hospitality industry as well as as
we've seen over the last few weeks and
domestically and get this just ramped up
a bit quicker the case numbers are down
the deaths are right down we're doing
doing pretty well so why can't we just
uh get things moving a bit quicker and i
think that'll be a question that a lot
of people are asking at the moment
as we see the government announce what
will be a pretty
small list of countries that are going
to be in the so-called green list which
means
you'll be able to return from these
countries on holiday quarantine free not
have to stay in quarantine
anywhere it's going to be a very small
list possibly just single figures and
it'll be
not necessarily your classic holiday
destinations maybe perhaps places like
malta gibraltar perhaps portugal i think
will be everyone's favorite on this
first one uh from may 17th
you can wait a little bit longer though
it sounds like beginning of june then
they'll open it up and we'll get it
we'll get those sort of likes of france
italy spain yeah and i think that'll be
uh that'll be when uh the double
vaccinated at least get to have a go
although i mean i haven't even had my
first vaccine yet so i'm
probably going to be able to leave the
country by about november yeah israel
and iceland potentially on that list
beautiful places to go but it's not
exactly the cost of del sol is it um as
you mentioned there
um alex let's move on to the metro the
lowest daily death toll
since last august and natalie i mean it
really is
good news isn't it that things are going
in the right direction
and you know hopefully we can see an end
to this
yeah i mean it's obviously good news
although
you know a death can never be really
good news but compared to what we were
seeing
exactly this time last year it's very
good news and
i think there's been some detail around
the last time we saw just
the deaths being this low was in august
last year um so you know that was in the
summer when everyone thought it was all
over and then it obviously
wasn't it came back again but one death
yeah great
and obviously we've seen um i think it
was matt hancock on twitter today
he did a very uplifting video saying 50
million people have had the first dose
of the vaccine now
and we can look forward to a great
british summer um
which unfortunately those pictures in
the metro doesn't really betray because
uh
boris was on the campaign trail in
hartlepool today and it was rather wet
and windy but
he's obviously um riding off the back of
this one death
50 million people have had the first
dose of the vaccine
and hopefully some good news coming next
month about holidays as well so
um i suppose the flip side of this of
course is that lots of people are going
to be saying well
with one death why can't you release us
sooner why can't we start going on
holiday sooner and mixing inside and
going to the theater and all those
things we used to do
one death is really really low yeah it's
an interesting it's an interesting point
you make there and alex
on the same page of the metro uh
pictures uh
from this weekend of that festival in
liverpool sefton park we know there was
the rave as well those big
trials to see if we can uh open up the
entertainment industry again all those
young people enjoying themselves without
social distancing without masks
and the prime minister saying today for
the first time that things are looking
very good
in terms of scrapping social distancing
um so i mean that's a long way off quite
unusual for the
for the prime minister to be so open
about something that is still somewhere
in the distance but it shows his
positivity doesn't it
it does and it also shows what he would
say would be the merits of his
very slow very cautious plan that he
always calls his irreversible plan that
he announced months and months ago about
his road map out of lockdown you know
the idea of having this incredibly
cautious you know idea of you know we
now are at the point with only one death
and we're still gonna have to wait six
weeks before
social distancing lifts inside um
inside pubs where where you know the
prime minister suggested today
that people will be able to you know
basically move around in uh inside pubs
without without masks and and
you know not not entirely lose uh lose
uh all of the aspects of
this sort of uh uh altered life that
we've had over the last year
but but basically get back to as close
to normal as is feasibly possible
but it's still six weeks off and you
know the thing is
you've seen that you see the metro you
see the daily mail you the prime
minister is going to come under a lot of
pressure i
mean i was sort of wondering over the
last few days if you know
while the prime minister was under so
much pressure politically over things
like wallpaper gate and
all of these sleaze allegations that
he's been mired in
might the government decide to you know
accelerate the pros accelerate the
process a little bit maybe get you know
get some get a bit of positive news out
there for the country and say you know
what things are going so well that we
can
move a little bit far ahead but it just
shows just how cautious
this prime minister is being having been
some would say
not appropriately cautious at earlier
points of the pandemic
this time around he's really not taking
you know any chances whatsoever
and we are going to have to wait until
june 21st for these uh these final
restrictions to be lifted
yeah okay uh let's leave things there i
want to talk about politics a little bit
more
after the break coming up with local
elections uh only a few days away now
taking place on thursday of course
kierstarma promises to clean up
politics discussing that next
hello again part two the press preview
still with me the editor of
nottinghamshire live natalie faye and
the editor of politico london playbook
alex wickham alex let's go straight to
the front of the guardian
uh it's going to be a a huge week this
week isn't it elections on thursday of
course kia stammer
is going to clean up our politics for
him
the the sleaze allegations still
something very much to go on
when it comes to trying to persuade
people to vote
labor that's right elections in england
wales and scotland uh on thursday and
that hartley pool bar election as well
which i think will be the real
box office event uh this week and yeah
kia starmer
has written a letter to the nation he
says in which he's
really going after boris johnson and
he's on he's on a campaign visit uh
tomorrow in which he really is going to
try and tie the conservative leader of
the prime minister
into these uh sleaze allegations that
he's been mired in
um everything from civil servants having
double
jobs and the prime minister charging a
donor allegedly for his wallpaper and
then not being very transparent about it
all the things that we've been hearing
over the last couple of weeks that
boris johnson hasn't really managed to
explain very clearly to the public
and we're going to see that's that
dreaded westminster jargon again but
we're going to see if this really has
cut through to the public and whether
the public really cares about it
and we've seen some polls over the last
few days
national polls westminster voting
intention polls which may not
necessarily
translate to these local elections into
this by-election but they appear to have
suggested a bit of a narrowing
in the in the polls between the
conservatives and the labour party
the tories were pretty clearly ahead
about even just over a week ago
quite quite a distance out of labor
seven eight nine points depending on
which pole you were going with up to 11
with with one pollster and that's
really started to narrow with quite a
few polls in a row now over the last few
days
which really could suggest if you're if
you're a kiestarma you'd be hoping that
it suggests that
some of these sleaze allegations have
actually you know got into the public's
mind and made them think twice about
voting conservative in some of these key
red rule red red wall
regions across the country now whether
or not that remains to be seen of course
we'll have to wait until thursday to
find out yeah well let's ask natalie her
opinion because of course
nottinghamshire
will be a key battleground uh on
thursday what are your viewers telling
you
uh well you know i think this is really
one of those westminster bubble kind of
stories i mean we keep seeing boris
johnson dodging questions on it which is
not a good look for him i've got to
admit
but i do think he's probably got a point
in this instance and it surprises me
that kierstama is still
sort of going along these lines of let's
talk about the sleaze all the time
whereas i i think i truly believe in
fact that people really want to know
what is the government going to do to
help people get jobs
um get back out of what the damage the
pandemic has caused you know
education jobs livelihoods all those
kind of things
and i honestly think that this is
probably the wrong kind of route for the
labour party to go down for this
election
but of course we'll see what happens on
thursday um as alex suggested there's
been a narrowing
in the polls uh the tories are still
leading though of course
um but you know the tories have had a
massive resurgence in nottinghamshire
um there were great many gains for the
tourism 2019 general election
nelsonshire county council is currently
held by the tories with the mansfield
independence as well
um you know i think i can probably see
it staying like that at the moment
because there's still riding high
very popular around here in
nottinghamshire which is a surprising
thing for me to sit here and say seeing
as it's a former mining county
and alex just uh uh very quickly uh
before we go
i see boris johnson tonight speaking to
conservative activists
really playing down uh the by-election
in hartlepool i think it's important for
people to understand this is not a seat
that conservatives
have ever held uh do you think he thinks
he's he's he's not going to win or do
you think it's um
sort of managing expectations
well this is that classic question is it
is isn't this just the prime minister
sort of saying
hang on a minute let's not get too
excited i don't want people to think if
we don't win that i've
had some massive failure uh this week
and so i think that is what he's just
slightly trying to do
at the moment where as we as we see you
know people perhaps starting to get a
little bit carried away with themselves
over the last couple of weeks saying oh
it's hartley paul's in the bag for the
for the conservatives
i don't think that is the case i mean it
it certainly is you know
as as johnson has said in these remarks
tonight
there's the seat has never been tory it
is it is a tough one for the tourists to
win yeah we shall find out anything so
i'm sorry
to cut you sure alex we'll find out of
course in the early hours of friday
morning
we're out of time but great to speak to
you both alex natalie thank you